[Music]
hey everyone how's it going today I'm
gonna be talking about how to get into
iOS development and quick note before we
start Thank You Squarespace for
sponsoring today's video whether you
need a domain or a website or an online
store
Squarespace it's got you covered so I
have been an iOS developer for about
four years now and I get a lot of
questions from Mel about how to get
started in iOS development so the reason
why I want to talk about iOS Feldman
this month is because next month
Apple is hosting their Worldwide
Developer Conference or WWDC which I'm
going to and so I want to make two
videos this month talking about iOS
development to get myself and yellow
hyped for dubbed MVC and so just to set
some context WWC is a week-long
conference hosted by Apple in the Bay
Area where they invite developers from
all over the world and talk about the
newest technology that's coming out in
the iOS developer community we often
call it Christmas because Apple brings
gifts to us that we have always wanted
and it's wonderful there are sessions
that are happening throughout the day to
learn about this new technology and
there are also labs so we can go and
talk to Apple engineers and ask any
specific questions I got to go for the
first time last year and it was so fun
and I'm stoked that I get to go again
this year so you can actually follow
along the first day of dobie do you see
there's a keynote where they announce
all of the new things and then they also
stream a lot of the major talks
throughout the week okay so let's jump
into today's topic now that we have some
context on why I really want to talk
about iOS this month okay so when people
ask me this question I often times lead
them to these three resources that I
think are great jumping-off points for
starting an iOS development by the way
don't worry everything that I'm gonna
talk about is going to be in the
description box below okay so let's talk
about that first of all so the first one
I'm going to recommend is a tutorial by
Apple so this specific one that I'm
pointing to is a step-by-step tutorial
on how to build your first iOS app it's
well written and explains things very
well and it's always up to date unlike
other parts of software engineering iOS
development is completely owned by one
company
Appl everything from the hardware to the
software to the IDE to the programming
language is what Apple owns and so they
all work really well together I think
it's called a closed ecosystem or a
closed world something like that Apple
has also in recent years made a huge
push to get more people into iOS
development if you remember the launch
of the playgrounds app on I've had a
couple of years ago I think that was
like one of the big first steps to get
more people into iOS development and
since then they've made a lot of
improvements to make iOS development a
lot easier to jump into so yeah
Apple documentation is going to be this
source of truth and is oftentimes the
most resourceful place to go to about
iOS development next one the second one
I highly recommend is Ray Wonderlic comm
this is an amazing online resource as
far as Apple tutorials go they have
extensive tutorials for Swift iOS TV OS
Mac OS wash OS and basically any topic
or album framework that you can think of
they have a bunch of tutorials on these
topics and they typically start off with
a starter project with step-by-step
instructions so at the end you'll have a
working app using the topic that you're
learning they're really useful and
they're really highly recommended by the
iOS community most of the tutorials are
free with the exception of some of these
starter packs or these more in-depth
guides but they have plenty of material
that's free that should get you well on
your way to starting iOS so yeah from
there you can start to learn whatever
piques your interest so if you want to
learn about iOS game development or if
you want to know about one very specific
thing about the maps framework then they
have tutorials that cater to all those
things I still use this site a lot
because I love how the tutorials give me
the experience of working with different
frameworks okay so the third one I
recommend is for those of you who do
really well learning from books and I
personally think the big nerd ranch
publishes the best iOS tutorial books on
the market I'm someone who learns really
well by doing things and so I love
tutorial based resources and big nerd
ranch has great books on iOS and Swift
programming that have detailed tutorials
on creating iOS apps I think I should go
get my
my boat here's my version of Swift
programming the big nerd ranch guide I
remember walking through this and
reading this a lot when I was just
starting Iowa's development and it was
really helpful albeit this is like a
pretty outdated version now because this
is also a 2.0 and swift is on four but
they come out with new versions all the
time with updated examples and code so
those are the three main resources that
I highly recommend for anyone wanting to
get into iOS development if you know of
any others please leave it in the
comments down below so yeah I personally
really love doing iOS development and I
think I'll keep doing it for a while but
I remember when I was first starting out
and I didn't have very many resources
around me and so hopefully these are
going to be helpful for you
I also remember that one of the hardest
things about starting iOS development
that kept me from starting for a long
time was that Xcode was just such a
mystery to me because I didn't know
where things were and what the buttons
meant so to help with that for anyone
else who's kind of stuck in that
scenario my second video that I'm gonna
make this month is kind of like a
walkthrough of Xcode I remember in
college I took a mobile programming
class and the very first office hour
session was the TA walking us through
how to use Xcode and he would show us
like you click here for this and like
this button does this in her to this go
here and it helped so much because I
remember I had tried doing iOS
development before but then I got stuck
because I had no idea how to use Xcode
and so once I figured out how to use
Xcode I was like oh this makes so much
more sense now so I hope that the
tutorial is going to help unlock some of
you and get you started
also I'll know that this will be one of
the very very few tutorials that'll make
on this channel I personally don't
really enjoy making tutorials I
mentioned this before but if you are
looking for more video tutorials on iOS
development there's a great channel
called let's build that app and he has a
bunch of videos on iOS and Swift
development so good at his channel if
you'd like to see more iOS video
tutorials ok honestly you're probably
talking about iOS development for a long
long time that makes so many videos
about it but I think I'm going to end it
here
again if you know of any other resources
on iOS development or you want to keep
advice you just watch chat whatever tell
me how are you doing leave a comment
down below and if you found this video
to be helpful please give it a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to my
channel and click the notification bell
to get notified for my videos again I
really want to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring today's video so here's
another use case where I say Squarespace
could be really great technical blogs
they're a great way to get your name out
there and also contribute back to the
technical community about things that
you know if you watch our video with Amy
Coates and you talked a little bit about
how important it is to teach others
because not only does it contribute back
to the community but it also emphasizes
that knowledge in your brain and
technical blogs are great for doing that
if you use Squarespace they have
beautiful designer templates that'll get
you going in no time it's an all-in-one
platform so you never have to install a
patch or upgrade anything ever so the
only thing that you have to think about
is writing stuff for your blog they have
award-winning 24/7 customer service and
so anytime you need help they're there
it's also really easy to set up a domain
or transfer one on Squarespace and so
you can brand it with whatever you'd
like so head on over to Squarespace comm
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to Squarespace comm slash
my you go for 10% off your first
purchase of a domain or website I'm
actually going to leave some of my
favorite technical blogs which are
mostly iOS based in the description box
below to give you some inspiration
that's it for today and I don't see you
next time bye
[Music]